[Narrator] What are you watching?
Because I have started watching stuff
I never would have watched otherwise,
I'm watching this show
that people tell me is been on forever.
That's called Selling Sunset.
It's like, and everyone watching is like
Conan where have you been?
But it's a reality TV show
where they just sell uh,
upscale real estate in West Hollywood.
I started watching that uh, and so.
I don't like real estate agents.
I don't want to spend time
with them in my free time.
I don't either.
I'm not even saying I'm enjoying it.
No.
I'm just.
They're taking advantage of us.
They've taken advantage of us.
It's a sign,
It's a sign of the times
that I'm watching a show
and my assistant told me
oh, it doesn't really get
good till season three.
Yes this is what people say.
(chuckles)
And I'm watching,
and that's what people say
and I'm watching it.
I'm watching his show and I'm going like,
yeah, it's still not
really nothing's happening,
but I guess I have to
watch two full seasons
till something picks up.
I never had that kind of
patience for a show before.
You figure that about The Wire.
Yeah got to get to the
season of age of Elba's
I think that season three
or four, like, okay.
I need to get thirty in.
(chuckles)
By the way season one
of The wire is great.
So it was a lie,
( chuckles)
whoever whoever said
that about any sh I mean,
but are you doing that now?
Or are you cause people have,
that's a common thing I keep hearing is
just get through five seasons
and then it really picks up.
But you've got to watch the first five.
You gotta get halfway through
season four Game Of Thrones.
Then it really kicks in.
(both chuckles)
My wife and I, we have so
many, you know, binging fights.
We're always fighting about that because
she does not follow any binge rule.
Like I will go somewhere, you know,
like say we get like a
little tiff, you know,
get a little tiff.
And we're watching,
like we're watching Prime
Suspect, starring Helen Mirren,
which is on Hulu, great
English show, classic old show.
I like how you said Helen Mirren,
Helen Mirren,
you went starring Helen Mirren. Like,
what are you going to do about it?
It's not a bar fight, Helen Mirren
(chuckles)
Helen Mirren . What are
you going to do about it?
You want to take me on now?
(chuckles)
Was it good?
So I said it starts Helen Mirren and huh.
Now it's Woody Allen.
(chuckles)
It's Helen Mirren, it's huh
And so we get like a little,
a little TIFF about something.
And then, you know, the
next time I turn it on.
She is three seasons forward,
shes lived three season
And also doesn't care.
Like, I'll go, well, what's going on?
She's like Google it, Google it.
Go read a summary of previous seasons.
And you know that's unfair
See to me, that's a contract.
If I'm watching something
with my wife and we,
there's an implicit implied contract,
that this is a show we watch together.
Then later on, I find out
that she's gone a whole
season ahead of me.
That's like waking up in the wilderness
and your partner left early in the morning
and took the thermos and the food.
(chuckles)
You know what I mean?
And you land and they're just gone.
They went up the trail without you.
That's a betrayal.
Yeah, my wife watched
the last season of The Crown without me.
And then you're in a
situation where you're like,
when am I going to get to watch it alone?
I don't have this kind of time.
I don't got eight hours where
you're going to let me hang
out alone to catch up on The Crown.
We have to be in sync as a couple.
This is very important.
We watch a lot of Dateline.
I find that, you know,
for some reason that's
our comfort show Dateline
because it's very, it's, you know,
it's a about murder trial really
but for some reason, the way they edit it,
they cut away before anyone has feelings.
(chuckles)
You know, they just, briskly
move through the murder.
You'll, you'll see a documentary
and somehow there's a murder
and people cry and they feel,
and you're devastated,
but Dateline it's, it's kind of bouncy
and light through murder .
I think it's strange too,
because I agree with you.
I love Dateline.
And I find it strange that murder
has become our comfort food.
Do you know what I mean?
It's just, this is where
the body was found.
The head's missing,
but we found one of the feet
and you're watching it like,
(clears throat)
this is, this is chicken
soup for the soul.
You know I don't know why.
I'm not sure why that is.
I don't know if it's like,
at least I haven't been
murdered or life is better than
this, but also I do feel like
I'm experiencing it with them,
but also I enjoy the hosts
because they're just so strange.
And they ask like weird questions
ever since Bill Hader did
impressions of every hosts.
I only think of Bill a lot
while I watch the show.
Cause they're always just going like,
well that must have felt good.
And I just think of Bill it's like
his head is on the screen.
Yeah. He ruined it for everybody.
Bill Hader ruined it for everybody.